is the message saying this app has been
such a game changer to me I've never
been so consistent with my Quran reading
before I knew about qurani and you can
get qurani absolutely free no credit
cards for seven day free trial what are
you waiting for download it now brown
sisters and build a habit with the
qurani app right now you can find the
link for IOS and Android in the link
description below
okay
what's aggressive about it well in terms
of sort of teaching and education going
to school
lots of cultures
what Muslims do I say this is Muslims
there are Muslims who go and commit
atrocities and blow themselves up yeah
Islam and muslimited this question women
are allowed to education yeah women are
allowed to education the rights that
women felt in Islam 1400 years ago the
Western woman got 100 years ago the
right to inherit before woman was
inherited she was a product she was
inherited the fact that you don't need
it as a Muslim like my wife doesn't have
to take my surname right this was this
100 years yeah the right to work the
right to own property yeah the Rival
Madam for example as if you for example
he was a Muslim woman if I was to
let's suppose somebody propose to you
yeah they have to go about it in a
certain way they have to speak to your
dad do you know why they have to speak
to your dad
because
a lot of the western women fall for this
trap of dating I believe it's the
biggest food because all you do is
you're coming across men you have no
idea what their agenda is and you're
committing to them and falling in love
with them and they are all after one
thing and they need to be broken and
they leave
yes no tell me why not
religious women yeah but in general say
in unhappy marriages because because
is one of the only religions that allows
a woman to get divorced she has a right
to divorce Jews Jewish in the Jewish
religion a woman is not allowed to It's
called The get she is not allowed to get
that until she's quite ironic she's not
allowed to get the get unless her
husband allows it so there was a
documentary on I think Netflix would
show us these women that are still stuck
with their husbands in Islam a woman has
a right to divorce this was also by in
the western world uh if I'm not mistaken
the Western woman feminism in the past
100 years I don't think they had a right
to divorce if I'm not mistaken 1400
years ago
you said but you said Islam oppresses
she has righteous you know if a woman is
not sexually satisfied sexually
satisfied with her husband
this is true yeah so the thing is he
assist us the things that you may have
heard in the newspaper wherever it may
be is false Islam gives coming back to a
man wanting to marry you listen for his
example if he wants to marry how to
speak to your dad is because he feels
any ulterior motives yeah you will not
want to speak to your dad number two
that if you do get married to him you
have a rightful down you know what
Darius
because a man knows a man and that in
itself
it's almost as if my father owns me no
not at all
no not at all because the thing is the
prophet peace upon him said no I can
force they lose to get married so this
false marriage concept is not understand
the reason it's your dad if it's not
your dad then it's your brother it's not
your brother it's your granddad because
what we see is a man knows a man so if
somebody comes to us
yeah and I believe certain times for
example a man might be able to deceive a
female yeah and it also happens
obviously as well there are women who
can do the same thing the reason why
it's there is to protect and maintain
the rise of a woman and that's what
Allah says in the Quran men are the
maintainers and Protectors of women now
when when this is said a lot of people
the Western woman take a step back why
don't need protection why do I need
maintain it but it's because the Western
world has made you believe
Miss Independent by the way a Muslim
woman can work my wife could work if she
wants and what's very interesting is her
money is her money so I can't touch her
money so if my wife is a millionaire and
I'm broke and I'm begging on the streets
and I can't touch my money so I'm just
saying the reason this is a place to
start is to say before party there is a
non-western woman there was a woman
actually he was on uh love Island
and she was Fed Up of getting into
relationships and with no end so you
have no security system don't make it
very clear
online no no no no there was things that
she mentioned about unstable
relationship her boyfriend said
something along those lines where she
was in relationships and she would
continuously wouldn't work they'll break
up Etc because every woman's dream to
have a nice wedding to have kids so you
think just because a father casts to die
over a man that stops all the sort of
relationship okay no no no no no no no
no no no no because religious drama
couples I'm not talking about that what
I'm trying to talk about is as a woman
God Almighty has um allowed and I don't
I don't know why the Western woman think
of this as like I think it's honorable
thing for your dad to look out for you
even if it's your dad if I spoke with
your dad today and you brought arguments
if you went through that I said I've got
a boyfriend he's not going to be like
over the moon it's going to be like okay
he would want to know because he cares
about you he'll caring about you it
doesn't mean oh you don't owe me he
loves you want you to this age he has a
damn right to care for you and know who
the hell is this guy
who's my mother no no problem I'm gonna
say Your mother does it as well I'm not
saying your mother's out of the picture
it's all about the man giving away no no
no no no no it's not the man's going no
no no it's not the man giving away woman
if you want to get married your dad has
to be in the picture this doesn't mean
your mom's not in the picture your mom
can read the picture as well the reason
why is the dad because a man knows a man
number one number two when it comes to
you getting married for example you have
a right to ask for Dowry you know what
diary is okay this can be anything you
can ask for a car you can ask for gold
you can ask for money yeah no matter
this doesn't make you a gold digger yes
you're right why is this the case why is
this the case why is there money
involved the wisdom might be is because
if a man has the wrong intentions you
might not mind talking to your dad
when money is involved yeah and when you
come and say to I want seven thousand
that's my doubt and that is yours by the
way that is your security why because
today we have men who go and sleep with
the hood of deadbeat dads yeah sleep
around and disappear she's left in a
financial crisis she's got a child
that's coming on the way and has no damn
security so this Dowry is in is in place
to protect you and secure you that if he
decides to go about the things the wrong
way and even when you're pregnant Allah
says in the foreign
milk money if I'm not mistaken he has to
provide basically he has to look after
you the Western woman today are
emotionally have you read a book called
Beauty sick I recommend you to buy it
yeah it talks about how women are made
to feel ugly and look at certain way not
happy with their body not happy how they
look can't leave the house without
makeup you have to spend two hours and
they added this and it's like two months
in one whole year yeah yeah the society
is making you feel ugly you have to look
certain way you have to understand body
you have to meet these standards for him
Islam says that there aren't men out
there for example who might be after the
wrong thing it tells you to cover up
yeah I believe women are being
sexualized today and people come and say
well hold on a second are you not
sexualizing the woman while covering her
up yeah when a man speaks to you even
when I'm talking to you now Sister
tell the believing men to lower their
case now what does that mean that means
if I'm walking down the road and I see a
woman dressing appropriately I should
look away
sexual objectification on a micro level
to a macro level because it educates a
man to respect a woman
talk about sort of women having to cover
up but men like you know you're causing
Temptation for the men because the men
can't control their case not necessarily
you know why because Allah Allah doesn't
say in the Quran men I mean no woman
cover up because men can't control the
case no because Allah says in the Quran
before he tells the woman he says tell
the believe in men to no other gays and
then tell the believing women to lower
their game so it starts off with a man
we both have to do our part men are
visual creatures that's why you have
strip clubs that's why you have certain
magazines and you do not you don't see a
woman buy a magazine to look at man's
calves it doesn't happen because the way
we're creating the way you crazy is
totally different yeah I do I believe I
believe that's culture I believe
why
exactly that's our point they can be
picked but the point is this is stuff
the reason not a cat called I spoke to a
girl and bigger than the circus and she
was punching the face because a guy
wanted a number and she didn't want to
give it the point I'm trying to make is
a following there are pigs out there
they exist so what Allah gives us is a
God Almighty gives us a way of life that
we can abide by now this like I said
before God doesn't say men can't control
their self so women cover up this is
nonsense what God Almighty tells us to
me is if a woman is in a bikini and
she's in a mini skirt and she's wearing
the cup you know in the cup
I have to know my case so the reason I'm
obviously I'm talking to you because I'm
having a discussion with you I'm trying
to say I'm not going to be standing here
just staring at you do what I'm trying
to say why because it shows you won't
lose our sister that Allah is telling us
men that you should respect women
they're not a sexual objects that's why
the needs to cover them up because
sister for example if we're doing our
part we expect you to do your part how
for example I'm low in my case I'm not
going to look at you I don't care how
you dress but this doesn't mean that
you're going to be rolling around in a
mini skirt Etc because there are not
many men like for example like myself
there are absolute idiots who might for
example try to touch you up
if they're actions of men that they
can't control them no no not really why
I said from the beginning it's a Muslim
man yeah our job is to know about our
kids but you need to understand as
Muslims forget Muslims
period If a woman who dress up in a
certain way I bet you any money
why the question is this just because
one is attracted like they catch the
difference in here that she has a right
to be raped I've never said such a thing
yeah nobody deserves right they're a
woman who whether he traveled
the issue of rape is going to have to do
with how you're dressed what we're
seeing is if God Almighty exists and
he's created me he's told me to lower my
gaze I'm going to do my bit if he tells
a woman to wear the hijab it's because
of God said it I'm just giving you maybe
the wisdoms behind why he might do it
the point here is this if he exists and
he tells me to climb a tree and come
back down and do five press-ups I'm
gonna do that because he's deserving a
worship and he's created me so the
argument goes back to who is telling us
what to do your mom and dad they brought
you to this age if you're the one that
said you darling I want to stick
Saturday and Sundays off don't go out
with your friends come and stand it sit
here and massage my feet I believe as a
mom and dad they deserve that period
because of what they've done now let's
compare that to God so the argument here
the hijab it might be that yes it might
protect you against certain men who are
viable but that's not the only reason
I'm saying that might be the wisdom
maybe maybe not that actual reason is
what because God almighty
and when a lot of times when girls are
being talked to yeah a lot of times men
took somewhere else they don't talk to
them yeah so if you realize when I refer
to you I refer to you as a sister I try
to have a decent conversation why
because as a woman why do you have to
feel like the only thing you have to
over is your body parts You Are a Human
Being you have so much more to offer
Humanity why does it reduce it to a
level of just Beauty that's the reason
why I read that book Beauty sit because
it shows you a pandemic of a millions
millions of women around the world if
you're insecure they feel ugly they feel
fat they don't want to come out there
was a woman who read that well I am a
man and I felt so bad she goes I felt so
ugly that I would go and sleep with men
that is you're taking a woman who can
offer this to the society and you're
dropping it all the way here because
she's made me feel ugly and she thinks
no man wants me so I'm gonna have to
sleep with them to feel somewhere that
is disgusting to me why has she been
made to go to such a level that she
feels sleeping with men because she
feels ugly and nobody would
want
yeah my question is this we have real
problems and we need practical Solutions
how do we deal with that I go down I'm
driving down the a406 and I see a banner
and the boss about that it's ever still
no Steel Company still and there's a
woman with a chili in her mouth and
everything what the flipping hell has a
blunt woman got to do with the steel
company I don't understand the
correlation
but the point is this a chocolate bar or
a car because Market the marketing
companies understand that men it grabs
their attention
a car has nothing to do with a woman but
we'll stick a heart make it go there
because they're gonna stare at it and
maybe they'll just look at the car and
say oh let me get that car the point is
this woman women have been sexualized to
such a level that they have no rights
and this is a pandemic we're talking
about millions or billions of women in
the Western World under the Muslims
don't get it twisted they're all Muslim
women before for this where they object
they beautify themselves the whole point
of hijab is not too beautiful yourself
it's total opposite so I'm telling you
it's a pandemic and we need to deal with
that because there are women who are
feeling insecure mental health is on the
rise how do we deal with this I believe
we deal with it by honoring women by
teaching them their self-worth yeah and
this is where I believe Islam gives a
practical solution no objectifying you
giving you rights 1400 years ago sister
do me a research the right to choose who
you want to marry the right to not adopt
take your husband's surname the right to
own property the right to divorce the
right to work there's so many elements
even in the Quran there's a verse called
Surah yeah and some people conversation
oh Islam says you know when I go home I
have a big stick and I beat my wife with
it yeah okay whatever in this verse God
Almighty is rebuking a man this is what
he said to his wife he said to his wife
to follow it he didn't hit her by the
way hitting your wife is not good he
said to her you are like the back of my
mother now now in those days that
basically meant I have no desire towards
you like basically you're just ugly yeah
that's a very important thing to say now
this woman goes to the prophet Muhammad
and complains and says my husband called
me this now the prophet Muhammad he
doesn't talk of himself he talks with
Revelation so the problem said look what
he said is wrong one but forgiven be
patient as she's walking out Revelation
comes down and in the Revelation look at
the punishment for him Allah says in the
Quran he's not mistaken he says that he
needs to fast for two consecutive months
you know in Ramadan we fast for 30 days
yeah so he needs to pass two consecutive
months and Ramadan that's 90 days of
Austin so the woman says look my husband
is old if he first is going to die he
can't fast he said okay he needs to free
a slave is that slave it was it was kind
of a property so he said he asked me
asleep he said look he doesn't have
sleeves said okay then he needs to feed
I think 60 people yeah he said he
doesn't have a penny yeah the point is
the following here all the man did was
insult his wife and Allah God Almighty
imagine the one who created the heavens
and the Earth
cares about a woman's feelings and sends
a revelation down one of the same sister
is there might be things that you heard
about Islam but look into it properly
because then you will understand
in every five people that come to Islam
free a woman do you know majority of
people that come to Islam are females
you know that majority of them there is
a woman called
Tony Blair's wife sister her name is she
actually works with our organization
she's a British woman same lifestyle Etc
now if you decide to try a name you can
see your story how she came yeah
there are many women why because women
who live for example this lifestyle in
the Western World they realize they
realize how rubbish they are treated
yeah I don't see it in general I'm not
saying they're really good men who are
not Muslim and they're good people I
don't get the truth I'm not saying all
all non-muslim men are bad the fun I'm
trying to make is that they realize the
lifestyle that they live it doesn't give
them that fulfillment you can have all
the money you know everything in the
world but you would have avoiding
because that void which Allah tells us
in the Quran is what not only in the
remembrance of God your hearts find
peace what that means is there is
nothing on this Earth
when you have that connection with God
trust me they can take everything from
you they can take your money your car
everything once you have that connection
you know your purpose you know why
you're here you know where you're going
that is something and any piece that no
one can buy and I have tasted that with
this stuff now that subject that's my
experience I'm not saying that's an
argument for Islam what I'm just saying
is sister is that give Islam a chance
yeah but nothing to lose have you got
Quran have you read the Quran before can
I give you one as a gift
it's this big
thing I would recommend you read the
Quran look into it and see for yourself
you know and if you do like I said
before I didn't show some evidences to
God's Almighty existence prayed it I
preached him uh maybe 12 years ago I
said if you're there guide me wherever's
away that's a relationship between you
and God so I would say you know give it
a try nothing to lose let's see what
happens